اهميه استراتيجيه تحظى بها المطارات في اي
نزاع مسلح والوضع في السودان ليس استثناء
لهذه الاهميه في قلب الخرطوم يقع مطار
العاصمه وهو الاكبر في السودان انشئ
المطار عام
1947 ومر بعده عمليات توسعه واعاده تاهيل
حتى بات مركزا ل 95% من حركه الطيران
الخارجيه في الاشتباكات الحاليه في
السودان كان مطار الخرطوم محورا رئيسيا
للاقتتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان المطار مدني وترتبط به
قاعده عسكريه جويه
اهميه اخرى يحظى بها مطار الابيض في
المدينه التي تحمل ذات الاسم على بعد 450
كيلومترا غرب الخرطوم فالمطار نقطه وصل
بين العاصمه ومعظم مناطق دارفور كما انه
مركز لقوات حفظ السلام الامميه في منطقه
ابياي المتنازع عليها بين السودان ودوله
جنوب السودان
اخيرا الى مطار مروي الواقع في الولايات
الشماليه وتتداخل فيه الاهميه الاقتصاديه
بالعسكريه هذا المطار كان من المشاريع
المصاحبه لانشاء خزان او سد مروي للاهميه
في الري وتوليد الكهرباء وكما هو الحال
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم يحتوي مطار مروي
بدوره على قاعده جويه
لمتابعه المزيد الكبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات